all righty so it's July and since balls
all happens in July in this game of big
game releases now is the chance for you
to get stuck into some of the great
games from earlier this year that may
have fallen by the wayside you know the
ones I'm talking that pile by the side
of your bed all the ones that are
clogging up your Steam library maybe you
installed them maybe you even watch the
intro sequence or played an hour or so
but you sure as hell didn't finish them
be sure to let me know your examples but
here are my picks let's start with an
obvious one watchdogs has been out for a
month and a half now so you really
should be more than an hour into it yeah
okay I'm only an hour into it whether
you're waiting out its price tag or
you've been distracted by transistor and
valiant hearts like I have July is the
perfect opportunity for you to get your
Chicago hacking on even if you have been
playing watchdog
there's so much you can get them into
the main story the side missions and the
multiplayer are all completely separate
entities that you can devote yourself to
depending on what you're interested in
Ubisoft sprawling worlds are so
frequently referred to as playgrounds
for a reason
also you can decide to crack into the
incessant car crashing and inability to
drive
I'd say that's been my forte in the game
so far
all righty so this entry is a little bit
biased since it is one of my favorite
games of 2014 surfer but since some of
you have expressed your love of RPGs in
the past
let's talk Might and Magic 10 legacy a
lovely nostalgic call back to when RPGs
crossed from pen and paper to computers
Might and Magic 10 is the latest
installment in this series of turn-based
old-school computer RPGs like a lot of
older RPGs the time sink sits at a tidy
forty odd hours depending on your
pension the side quests but the game has
a great monster and quest heavy world
and the turn-based combat demands enough
tactical forethought that you'll rarely
find yourself bored if you rue the day
devs decided to oversimplify and
modernize RPGs then this will well and
truly grab your interest then again if
slow-paced really detailed RPGs are not
your things dear clear and maybe try out
this next one the pacing on this next
one is pretty dependent on you and your
skill level or the number of times you
ragequit while you may get sick of other
games out of boredom or being
overwhelmed this one will probably come
to a fast end due to a broken controller
oh is that just me that's right I'm
talking about from software's Dark Souls
2 it's pretty widely considered to be a
phenomenal game but it's not everybody's
cup of tea since July is relatively
quiet it could be worthwhile taking some
time to make this game your [ __ ] you
know so it's not always the other way
around
Dark Souls 2 is the sort of RPG that
demands mastery of its different
elements exploration character
optimization and obviously combat and
this is totally possible it just takes
time for some people an awful lot of
time last up is the game I'm betting you
either completed and felt pretty good
about all you completely forgot it
existed either way south park the stick
of truth is a real gem and a lot of fun
so you should probably finish it
assuming you have a fairly high
tolerance for crass humor and some base
understanding of South Park this is a
surprisingly great game considering its
base on a TV show honestly even just as
an RPG it's great the combat can exist
within a turn-based realm or you can
beat your foes to the metaphorical and
literal punch by using the environment
to incapacitate your enemies before you
get into the fight one of the best parts
of the game is exploring the reference
riddle town of South Park and getting
stuck into all the side quests you find
along the way you're also able to chop
and change your practical and aesthetic
gear to make your chosen one exactly who
you want them to be and that is it was
just as favorite RPGs of 2004 I'm sorry
games you should finish in July be sure
to let me know your 2014 favorites in
that comment event down below last week
I talked to you guys about some of my
very favorite trailers from the e3 that
didn't get quite so much attention here
were your favorite games of the show
Lawrence Van Ryn pitched in his love the
sunset overdrive which I totally echo
saying sunset overdrive was the best one
it actually made me consider getting an
Xbox one for something I refused until
that trailer
insomniac rocks hailer us added about
Tomb Raider I couldn't care less about
the other four picks are just amazing I
did see Newman sky and re here on GS but
missed the other two yeah if the game is
putting so much effort into art
direction and finally Brennan Chaudhary
chipped in with no man's sky want us to
convert in your book perf that's about
right
be sure to leave me a comment letting me
know what is on your to play list for
this week and if there's any games
you've been meaning to get stuck into
for a while I'll see you again next week
you